Antes de empezar quiero haceros un anuncio
muy especial: Estamos en año de mundial,
así que hemos querido preparar algo súper
novedoso en el canal, algo que creemos que
os va a encantar: La liga VisualPolitik.
De la mano de nuestros amigos de Biwenger,
hemos puesto en marcha una liga Fantasy, dónde
podremos competir entre todos.
Participar en la Liga VisualPolitik es algo
muuuuuy sencillo y, por supuesto, totalmente
gratuito.
Y ademñas podréis conseguir premios:
Simplemente tenéis que seguir el enlace que
os dejamos en los comentarios y en la descripción,
y una vez os descarguéis la app de Biwenger
- si es que no la tenéis ya - os llevará
directamente a nuestra liga.
Entonces tan sólo tendréis que asignar un
nombre a vuestro equipo y…
Listo, ya estaréis preparados para gestionar
vuestro propio equipo y enfrentaros a Fonseca,
a Enrique y a mi.
Empezaréis con un equipo aleatorio y un presupuesto
con el que podréis fichar jugadores..
Por ejemplo, ¿Confias en la campaña que
hará Lewandowski?
¿Crees que Benzema volverá a salirse otro
año más?
Pues ya sabes.
Por supuesto, también podrás vender jugadores
para hacer caja.
Porque y esto es importante, siempre, siempre
tendrás que tener las cuentas en positivo
para poder puntuar.
Así que ya sabes: perfila tu plantilla, escoge
tu alineación, tu capitán…
Y empecemos.
La pregunta es, ¿Crees que podrás derrotar
al equipo de VisualPolitik?
Pues venga, apuntaros a la Liga VisualPolitik
en Biwenger y preparos para competir.
La popularidad del presidente norteamericano
Joe Biden está por los suelos.
Bueno, que digo por los suelos, se ha hundido
de tal forma que prácticamente podemos decir
que se está sumergiéndo en las fosas más
profundas del océano electoral.
Prestad mucha atención a los datos: a mediados
de julio del 2022 algunas encuestas sugerían
que el 71% de los votantes no querían que
se volviera a presentar, incluido el 54% de
los demócratas.
Un porcentaje, este último, que se incrementa
hasta el 94% entre los jóvenes demócratas
de entre 18 y 29 años.
El 94%.
N1(La Casa Blanca se enfrenta a un desastre
con los votantes jóvenes.
Cada vez hay más temores entre los demócratas
de que estén en peligro de perder una generación
si no mejora su posición ante la Generación
Z.
The Hill)
Y eso no es todo.
Si tomamos una media de encuestas podemos
ver que el nivel de aprobación del presidente
no deja de caer.
Tal y como podéis ver, desde su toma de posesión,
en apenas año y medio su nivel de aprobación
ha caído 20 puntos.
[Una locura]
Pero, ¿cómo es esto posible?
¿Qué explica semejate debacle en la valoración
del presidente?
Pero…
volviendo a Biden, si somos justos, desde
la caótica, indigna y desastrosa forma en
la que se produjo la retirada de Afganistán
- algo que aquí en VisualPolitik criticamos
duramente - el equipo formado por el Presidente
Biden, el Secretario de Estado, Antony Blinken
y el Secretario de Defensa, Lloyd Austin,
ha cosechado bastantes tantos en política
exterior...
Y no me refiero a tantos precisamente pequeños:
Por ejemplo, estos 3 personajes están liderando
el apoyo norteamericano y occidental a Ucrania
en una guerra que ha desbaratado por completo
los planes del Kremlin y que ha destrozado
una buena parte de la capacidad militar rusa.
También han sido capaces de consolidar y
cohesionar tanto la OTAN como la relación
atlántica.
De hecho, con Biden, Washington ha vuelto
a ser todo un líder en el viejo continente
y hoy la Organización del Tratado del Atlántico
Norte parece más fuerte que nunca.
Y no se trata solo de la vieja Europa, en
Asia está ocurriendo tres cuartas partes
de lo mismo:
(La política firme de esta administración
ha desbordado, ha superado por completo las
ambiciones chinas de hacerse con la hegemonia
regional.
Por ejemplo, ahí tenemos los casos del programa
AUKUS que busca hacer de Australia una superpotencia;
o el fortalecimiento de las relaciones con
Japón y Corea del Sur, a este último dándole,
por cierto, plena libertad para el desarrollo
de misiles balísticos.
También podemos mencionar la reiteraa defensa
de Taiwán, la mejora de las relaciones bilaterales
entre los aliados de Estados Unidos en la
zona, el fortalecimiento del Quad o el nuevo
Marco Económico del Indopacífico)
Os hemos hablado de todo ello en un pasado
vídeo aquí en VisualPolitik.
La actividad de la administración Biden en
el Pacífico está siendo casi tan frenética
como en Europa.
Pero es que incluso en Oriente Medio, donde
las relaciones de Biden con el gobierno saudí
son francamente malas, su administración
está apoyando la creación de una especie
de nueva alianza militar que incluye además
de varios países árabes al estado de Israel.
Es decir, que hablamos de un fortalecimiento
del peso, la influencia y las relaciones de
Estados Unidos como hacía décadas no conocíamos.
Sin embargo, un momento porque pese a ello
la popularidad de Biden está más fría que
un témpano de hielo en plena Antartida.
Y la pregunta, la gran pregunta es: ¿Cómo
demonios es esto posible ? ¿Qué diantres
explica que la popularidad del presidente
se haya desplomado de semejante forma?
Pues...
Queridos amigos, amiga, la respuesta quizás
tenga que ver con las constantes meteduras
de pata, como cuándo dijo que tenía cancer
y la Casa Blanca le tuvo que desmentir.
O puede que directamente tenga que ver con
que es más que evidente que el presidente
está mayor, muy mayor.
Lo que entre otras le hace incapaz de vender
sus logros.
Pero honestamente creo que también tiene
que ver con esto:
Así es, hablamos de lo que podemos calificar
como el gran fracaso del Bidenomics.
Porque, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
cuando Joe Biden ganó las elecciones no solo
prometió una regeneración institucional,
también prometió dar un giro de 180 grados
a la política económica para que el gobierno
federal volviera a liderar la "reconstrucción"
de los Estados Unidos de América.
Incluso, hubo quien describió la llegada
de Biden como la puesta en marcha de un nuevo
paradigma económico que pondría fin, de
una vez por todas, a la América basada en
los bajos impuestos, el estado pequeño y
la desregulación de Ronald Reagan - como
si algo así siguiera existiendo.
Y no penséis que tan solo fue algo exógeno.
El propio entorno de Biden defendió que su
llegada al poder conllevaría algo prácticamente
equivalente al New Deal de Roosevelt tras
la Gran Depresión de 1929.
(De esta forma durante la campaña electoral
Biden habló de cosas como recuperar el peso
sindical, luchar decididamente contra el cambio
climático, cancelar la deuda estudiantil,
ordenar el caos migratorio o reconstruir las
viejas infraestructuras norteamericanas.
Y sobre todo habló y mucho de estimular la
inversión, la privada y sobre todo, y liderando
la nueva economía, la inversión pública.
Así que, en cierto modo, podemos decir que
cambio de paradigma o no, lo que sí que prometió
claramente Joe Biden fue reconstruir Estados
Unidos con una agenda muy demócrata.)
Sin embargo, desde entonces....
Los resultados no han sido exactamente los
esperados.
En algunos casos porque los proyectos se han
estancado o han terminado en casi nada.
Y en otros porque bueno....
Creo que los titulares hablan por sí solos:
(13 de julio del 2022: Estados Unidos: La
inflación del 9,1% registró en junió un
nuevo máximo en 40 años.
Politico)
(25 de julio del 2022: Los datos muestran
que la economía de EE. UU. se tambalea ante
la recesión.
CNBC)
Pero...
¿En qué ha fallado exactamente el Bidenomics?
¿Qué no está funcionando con la actual
política de la Casa Blanca?
¿Qué está provocando que los norteamericanos
suspendan rotundamente al actual presidente?
Pues bien...
Veámoslo.
T1(UNA REVOLUCIÓN A MEDIO GAS)
La presidencia de Biden comenzó con una actividad
frenética, pero, al final, terminada la primera
mitad del 2022 esta Administración había
conseguido básicamente tan solo 3 cosas con
su nueva política económica:
Un plan de lucha contra el Covid algo más
pequeño que el de Trump y que se convirtió
en auténtica gasolina para la inflación.
Un incremento mediante órdenes y directivas
presidenciales del gasto del gobierno durante
la próxima década de 530 mil millones de
dólares.
Un incremento fundamentalmente destinado a
mejorar el conocido como Programa de Asistencia
Nutricional Suplementaria, un plan de cupones
para familias de bajos ingresos.
Y, por último, un proyecto bipartito de infraestructuras
muuucho más pequeño de lo que había prometido.
(Luego, todo hay que decirlo, a finales de
julio de 2022, la administración Biden ganó
por sorpresa los votos para sacar adelante
el conocido como proyecto de Ley de Reducción
de la Inflación, una ley que contempla varias
subidas de impuestos, entre ellas el pago
mínimo del 15% sobre beneficios o una ampliación
sin precedentes del sistema de recaudación
fiscal.
También cientos de miles de millones de dólares
en nuevo gasto.
Por ejemplo, 385 mil millones se destinarán
a combatir el cambio climático, impulsar
el coche eléctrico y reforzar la producción
de energias limpias.
Aun así la ley es apenas una fracción de
la promesa inicial de la Administración.
Y practicamente todas las demás políticas
del Bideonomics han encallado, y teniendo
en cuenta la bajísima popularidad del presidente
y la mejora de intención de voto de los republicanos,
no parece que esta "revolución sin gas" puede
ir mucho más allá, ni con la presente administración
ni con una próxima.)
[Claro, ¡A ver quién es el guapo que se
atreve a coger semejante cuchillo cayendo
al vacio!]
Por supuesto, esto no quiere decir que la
presidencia de Biden haya terminado, ni mucho
menos.
La situación internacional ha puesto en el
foco de la diana a la política exterior.
Y como ya hemos comentado ahí la Administración
Biden está de todo menos quieta.
Sin embargo, en lo que respecta a la política
económica...
El suspenso parece más que probable.
Y para colmo, puede que lo peor para la popularidad
del presidente no esté haciendo sino comenzar:
(26 de julio de 2022: Una encuesta de la CNBC
muestra que la mayoría de los inversores
y economistas consideran que las subidas de
tipos de la Reserva Federal causarán una
recesión en el plazo de un año)
Pero más allá de lo que no ha podido sacar
adelante, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es...
¿En qué se ha equivocado exactamente Joe
Biden?
Atentos.
(LO QUE AMÉRICA NO NECESITABA)
Queridos amigos, amigas basicamente, el Presidente
y su equipo diagnosticaron mal la situación
de la economía norteamericana.
Y a partir de ahí todo fue en cierto modo
de mal en peor:
Un ejemplo, lo tenemos con el plan de choque
contra la pandemia de Biden, que vertió decenas
y decenas, cientos de miles de millones sobre
la economía norteamericana cuándo esta se
estaba ya recuperando mucho más rápido de
lo previsto: ¿el resultado?
Gasolina sobre una inflación galopante.
Y eso no es todo.
Por ejemplo, dentro del plan anterior destacó
un crédito fiscal prácticamente universal
y según el caso pagadero en efectivo de hasta
300 dólares mensuales por niño.
Una iniciativa que la Administración Biden
pensó sería recibida con los brazos abiertos
por la ciudadanía norteamericana, lo que
les permitiría consolidarla de forma permanente.
Pues bien, nada más lejos de la realidad,
apenas un tercio de los estadounidenses apoyan
que esta política sea permanente...
Lo que, por supuesto, permitió que los republicanos
decidieran que no votarían por su renovación
más allá del primer año.
(Según una encuesta sólo 1 de cada 3 [norteamericanos]
quieren que la ampliación de los créditos
fiscales por hijos sea permanente.
The Hill)
Pensadlo bien, ¿por qué apoyar que el gobierno
entregue permanentemente cheques de efectivo
en un contexto en el que hay mucho trabajo
disponible y salarios crecientes?
Sea como sea, lo que está claro es que una
de las medidas estrella de esta administración
no consiguió hacerse con la simpatía general.
Pero lo que sí hizo fue costar mucho dinero,
incrementar la deuda pública y alimentar
aún más la inflación.
(En esta misma línea, el diagnóstico de
que la América más pobre se estába quedando
atrás y que por tanto necesitaba que el gobierno
promoviera nuevos empleos simple y llanamente
no era cierto.
De hecho, desde el 2010 han sido precisamente
los salarios más bajos los que más han estado
creciendo.
Así que, más esfuerzos, más dinero y nuevas
regulaciones tiradas por la borda.)
Y luego tenemos los impuestos.
La obsesión de esta administración está
siendo subir los impuestos a las empresas
y supuestamente a los más ricos.
El problema es que, por ejemplo, las subidas
del impuesto sobre los beneficios de las empresas
del 21% al 28% defendida por Joe Biden no
solo haría que Estados Unidos volviera a
tener uno los tipos impositivos más elevados
de todo el mundo desarrollado sino que además
contribuiría a frenar la inversión de las
empresas, ralentizar la economía e incrementar
los costes de producción.
Exactamente lo que no hay que hacer en tiempos
de inflación.
Para colmo otra cosa que no tuvieron en cuenta
los demócratas es que en los últimos años
ha vuelto a elevarse el porcentaje de familias
que tienen invertidos sus ahorros y sus planes
de pensiones en bolsa.
Familias a las que por supuesto medidas como
esta no les hace ninguna gracia.
(12 de mayo del 2022: Gallup encuentra en
su encuesta de Economía y Finanzas Personales
de abril, que el 58% de los estadounidenses
poseen acciones.
Esta cifra es ligeramente superior al 56%
de 2021 y al 55% de 2020.
Gallup)
Resumiendo, Biden ha impulsado una política
económica basada en grandes planes de gasto
público e incrementos de impuestos que la
sociedad no necesitaba, que la sociedad no
quería y que ni siquiera era conveniente
dado el contexto económico.
Una política que, además, ha terminado por
impulsar la mayor inflación de los últimos
40 años.
Lo que a su vez ha obligado a reaccionar a
la Reserva Federal.
Lo que a su vez parece que va a terminar con
la economía norteamericana entrando en recesión,
el gobierno dilapidando cientos de miles de
millones de dólares y las familias perdiendo
poder adquisitivo.
[Vamos que la cosa no podía haber salido
peor, al menos desde el punto de vista de
la popularidad del Bidenomics]
Y esperad un momento, porque no, aún no hemos
terminado.
Otro de los grandes cambios prometidos por
la administración Biden tenía que ver con
la transición enerética y la lucha contra
el cambio climático.
Algo que, la verdad, ya de entrada con los
datos en la mano, como decirlo, no genera
precisamente mucho entusiamo entre el público
estadounidense, particularmente en momentos
como este.
Fijaos.
“Solo el 1% de los votantes mencionó el
cambio climático como el problema más importante
que enfrenta el país, muy por detrás de
las preocupaciones sobre la inflación y la
economía.
Incluso entre los votantes menores de 30 años,
el grupo que se pensó que estaba más motivado
por el tema, esa cifra fue del 3%”.
David Wallace_Wells, columnista del NYT)
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que el equipo
de Biden puso a la industria petrolera en
el centro de su diana.
Nada más llegar a la Casa Blanca el presidente
comenzó a emitir una tras otra órdenes ejecutivas
contra la industria del petróleo.
(De esta forma, entre otras medidas, el presidente
Biden paralizó las explotaciones en el Refugio
Nacional de Vida Silvestre del Ártico, canceló
la construcción del oleoducto Keystone X
con Canadá, ordenó a las agencias del gobierno
estudiar nuevas reglas para frenar el consumo,
congelar permisos, subir los impuestos y reducir
la financiación de las compañías petroleras
Incluso estableció una moratoria al arrendamiento
de tierras federales para buscar y explotar
petróleo.
Todas estas medidas no solo buscaban castigar
a la industria del petróleo norteamericana
sino que sobre todo pretendían enviar un
mensaje muy claro al mercado: el que no merecía
la pena invertir grandes cantidades de dinero
en el sector petrolero porque el gobierno
lo iba a castigar.)
Visto lo visto, craso error.
Todas estas políticas que hemos visto supusieros
dopar la demanda y al mismo tiempo dañar
la oferta justo cuándo la economía se estaba
recuperando a toda velocidad.
Es posible que sin las acciones de Biden las
cosas no hubieran sido muy diferntes..
O quizás sí, lo que está claro es que el
Bidenomics ha ido en la dirección equivocada
y que se ha convertido en uno de los grandes
culpables de los desequilibrios económicos
que hoy castigan a las familias norteamericanas.
Porque amigos, amigas, Biden si podía haber
muchas cosas.
Atentos.
T3(LO QUE AMÉRICA SÍ NECESITA)
Si Biden quería mejorar el nivel de vida
de las familias estadounidenses su prioridad
tendría que haber sido tomar medidas para
promover la inversión, tanto pública como
privada.
En el caso de la inversión pública, os lo
hemos contado en nuestro boletín de Patreon,
el problema es que el gobierno federal cada
vez gasta más pero cada vez invierte menos.
Es decir, la inmensa mayor de todo el presupuesto
se destina a gasto asistencial o no productivo.
De esta forma, en lugar de invertir en investigación
o infraestructuras, como las autopistas interestatales
o la presa Hoover, el gasto se ha trasladado
mayormente al bienestar social, la defensa
y el servicio de la deuda.
Fijaos.
(Si sumamos el gasto en defensa y el pago
a individuos - salarios, subsidios y rentas
de todo tipo - entonces podemos explicar el
85,4% de todo el gasto federal en comparación
con el 71,2% que representaban en 1990.
Esto quiere decir que a pesar de los grandes
déficits públicos el desembolso en el resto
de partidas como infraestructuras, exploración
espacial o I+D+i está siendo aplastado.
Es decir que la inversión pública cada vez
es en proporción más pequeña)
Y para colmo la inversión neta de las empresas
norteamericanas también ha venido cayendo
desde hace casi 40 años.
Fijaos.
Intentar cambiar esta tendencia con políticas
de oferta hubiera contribuido decisivamente
a frenar la inflación y mejorar el poder
adquisitvo de las familias norteamericas a
largo plazo.
Pero dentro del Bidenomic todo esto era la
parte más pequeña.
En definitiva: sí, el desempleo se encuentra
prácticamente en su menor nivel desde 1969,
pero no ocurre lo mismo con las tasas de empleo
- cuya recuperación está siendo mucho más
lenta.
Y eso por no olvidar que por culpa de la enorme
inflación, los salarios reales están contrayéndose.
Lo que explica que el sentimiento del consumidor
sea casi tan bajo como lo fue durante la gran
crisis del 2008.
Fijaos.
¿Y qué significa esto?
Pues que hoy por hoy - y quizás sin mucho
motivo - los consumidores estadounidenses
son pesimistas sobre el futuro próximo.
Y lo son en gran medida porque entienden que
el Bidenomics no ha funcionado para nada.
Digamos que no importa que los fundamentales
de la economía norteamericana parezcan robustos:
Biden llegó con un plan que no ha contribuido
sino a empeorar las cosas.
Y, amigos, amigas, esta es una de las razones
que explican la baja popularidad de Joe Biden.
Así que no importa que su Administración
está cosechando muchos tantos en política
exterior, si el panorama económico no cambia,
la presidencia de Biden no pasará a la historia
como una presidencia popular.
Pero dicho esto turno para ti: ¿Qué opinión
te merece el Bidenomics?
¿Crées que la actual administración está
a tiempo de cambiar de marcha y conseguir
mejores resultados?
¿Crees que se está siendo excesivamente
injustos con ella?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y
abramos debate.
Y por supuesto si este vídeo te ha parecido
interesante no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.